So in the DOS-like structure, the main
difference from the monolithic structure that I
showed you earlier is that the red
line separating the application from the operating system
is now replaced by a dotted line. What that means, the main difference is
there is no hard separation between the
address space of the application And the address
space of the operating system. The good
news is an application can access all the
operating system services very quickly. As they would
any procedures that they may execute within their
own application with the same speed. At
memory speeds, an application can make calls into
the operating system and get system services. That's
the good news. But the bad news is
that there is no protection of the
operating system from inerrant application. So, the
integrity of the operating system can be
compromised by a runaway application, either maliciously
or unintentionally corrupting the data structures that
are in the operating system. Now, you
may wonder why DOS Chose this particular structure. Well, at least in the early
days of PC, it was thought that a personal computer, as the name
suggests, is a platform for a single user and, more importantly, the vision was,
there will be exactly one app that is running at a time. Not even multitasking.
So performance and simplicity was the key and protection was not primary concern
in the DOS-like structure. And that you can
get good performance comes from the simple observation
that there is No hard separation between the
application and the operating system. The operating system
is not living in its own address space.
The application and the operating system are in
the same address space. And therefore, making a
system call by an application is going to happen as
quickly as the application would call a procedure
which the application developer wrote himself or herself.